Marvel Studios are shrouded as plans for
the Disney Plus streaming service and
its usual failed of secrecy but we've
already gotten a pretty good peek at
some of the shows and developments
here's everything we know about their
plans so far in November 2018 Disney
confirmed a number of the original
series and development including a Loki
series starring Tom Hiddleston there
were still no details about when this
series will be set or how it was
possible considering Loki's death and
Avengers infinity war we had so many
questions and then came Avengers endgame
with an answer when the Avengers go back
in time to the events of 2012's Avengers
they inadvertently give Loki the
opportunity to steal back the tesseract
and escape from their custody directors
Joe and Anthony Russo confirmed a few
weeks after endgames release that the
Loki of the past created an alternate
timeline when he escaped it hasn't been
confirmed that this will be the version
of Loki viewers follow in his upcoming
limited series but it certainly seems
like the most likely possibility while
rumors floated around for a while it
took until April 2019 for the Scarlet
Witch series to be confirmed and once it
was we learned it wouldn't be just
Scarlet Witch during a Disney investors
meeting a Kevin Feige revealed the show
would be called one division and would
feature the return of not only Elizabeth
Olsen and Scarlet Witch but Paul Bettany
as the Android vision as well what we
know about one division is both
intriguing and the little confusing
vision died in Avengers infinity war and
unlike Scarlet Witch wasn't revived an
endgame Olsen's talk with Variety later
in April revealed more puzzling details
about the show specifically that at
least part of it will apparently have a
retro aesthetic she dished that the show
story would be pulled from quote quite a
few other comic books and pointed out
that quotes at the Disney Plus launch
chat they showed a photo of Scarlet
Witch envisioned in the 50s in May 2019
a rumor circulated suggesting scarlet
witch's powers will become more
comic-book accurate in Wonder vision
meaning to gain access to reality
altering abilities while there's been no
confirmation that this would go a long
way to explain how vision is apparently
coming back to life
you couldn't have done that earlier I
hate you
in October 2018 if a variety reported
Anthony Mackey's Falcon and Sebastian
Stan's Bucky aka the Winter Soldier
would be partnering up for their own
limited series on Disney plus a story
claimed would be the first of the Disney
Plus MCU original series to find a
writer naming Empire producer and writer
Martin Spellman the series titled Falcon
and Winter Soldier was confirmed in
April 2019 with Wonder vision when Kevin
Feige addressed as the investors since
then we've learned more details about
the show than any of the other confirmed
Disney Plus MCU series the following
month a deadline reported Falcon on
Winter Soldier would be six episodes
long and that director Carey Skoglund
known for a work on The Handmaid's Tale
Nosferatu and The Walking Dead among
others have been recruited to direct the
entire show at the justin bellow
comic-book convention in Italy Stan
hinted the series would give Bucky the
chance quote to go out there and have an
identity outside of the circumstances
that we've met him through along with
naming Scotland as director deadlines
release other details the site reported
Emily VanCamp who played Sharon Carter
in Captain America the Winter Soldier
and Civil War is in talks to appear in
the series as well as Daniel Bruhl who
played civil wars villains emo according
to Deadline at the series is scheduled
to be released on Disney Plus in August
20 2011 to weeks before the April 2019
release of Avengers endgame Variety
reported a Hawkeye series starring
Jeremy Renner was in the work for Disney
Plus few details have been released
about the Hawkeye series but The
Hollywood Reporter says the show will
follow Clint Barton as he passes the
torch to another Archer hero the
upcoming series will revolve around
Barton trading the younger Kate Bishop
to take over the mantle of Hawkeye in
the comics Bishop initially takes the
name after Barton dies in the 2004 event
Avengers disassembled once Barton
returns to the land of the living as
most people who died Marvel Comics
eventually do both heroes keep the
Hawkeye name this has all been covered
extensively in the comics but as of now
there's no word on Hulk Kate Bishop
enters Clint Barton's life or who will
be playing her in the series in mid
April 2019 a rumor circulated that
Marvel was developing a Hulk she-hulk
series with Mark Ruffalo reprising his
role as Bruce Banner at the Hulk
I put the brains and the Brawn together
and now look it
best of both worlds according to the
story she-hulk would ultimately be the
focus of the series in the comics she
Hulk is Bruce banners cousin Jennifer
Walters banner inadvertently creates
she-hulk after his cousin his shots with
no other viable donors available he's
force of a former blood transfusion and
give his own Hulk infected blood to his
cousin since the initial rumor broke not
many details of surfaced about the
series however since the release of
Avengers endgame we now know the Hulk
whose right arm is rendered permanently
damaged after using the Infinity stones
probably won't be doing a lot more
superhero stuff so if the rumors about
the series are true it could be the Hulk
will find himself much in the same
position as Hawkeye in his series
teaching a new hero to fill his shoes in
February 20 19 while promoting Captain
Marvel Marvel Studios chief Kevin Feige
told Collider the upcoming Disney Plus
MCU series will be important to the
quote entire post and game MCU Feige
also said the series were all conceived
together and that they would be
intertwined with each other as well as
the studio's movies now that Avengers
end game has been released along with
spider-man far from homes final trailer
we know some of the things are different
than the MCU since endgame new world
Beck is from Earth just not ours in
particular we now know that the earth of
the MCU is connected to a fat multiverse
of alternate timelines which are now
apparently much more connected than they
used to be ever since a nose has big
snap parallel worlds bring up
potentially limitless possibilities it's
probably why a once dead Loki will be
able to lead his own series and it could
also be wider suppose the lead dead
vision and the freshly revived Scarlet
Witch will be back together again in one
division check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and to the Bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]